the total number of coronavirus cases
going up to 590 from 456 yesterday yeah
it's a big rise we have 456 yesterday
more cases today the trajectory is
carrying on very much the way the
experts had predicted now we've had a
number of cases a large spike I believe
in Scotland I'm just trying to find some
more information about some information
that has just been sent to me but yes
certainly this is a it's it's a
significant spike but we can't exactly
tell what those figures mean Ashish were
just understanding that two more
patients have died in UK hospitals from
covin 19 that's coming from NHS England
so that brings the total who sadly died
- Ted - 10 yeah we had two more
yesterday again elderly patients with
underlying health conditions it's not
not on expect it's not unexpected but
what I'm trying to say is that the
figures will only make sense of people
who are modelling at the moment right so
the government will look at these
figures and they'll look at what's
happening across Europe they will then
decide when the time is right to move
into the delay phase that the figures
don't tell us anything on their own at
the moment right so we have we know that
the elderly and people with underlying
health conditions are the most effective
are most affected and we know that the
number of dead is expected to rise over
the coming weeks we the spike is about
three to five weeks away what we're
waiting on now is what the government
intends to do about its next phase its
strategy if the delay phase and moving
into that to prevent mass gatherings
people children go to school encouraging
people to stay at home and work from
home all of this will not be led by the
number of people who are being infected
and the number of people who are dying
it will be decided by the scientists who
think it will be the right time to move
into that phase yes they where the World
Health Organization calling this a
pandemic that would have been another
trigger if the government needed one to
move into the next phase
certainly what is happening across
Europe with Island and France and
Germany and Poland and Denmark those
countries and Esley of course those
countries taking quite what some people
might suggest is quite drastic actions
shutting down movement within society
shutting down workplaces stopping people
from gathering stopping people going out
shopping i shops in italy they're the
only ones that are open at the moment
our food shop serve pharmacies so this
is serious action but then the pressure
on the United Kingdom is that these
leaders these medical experts across
Europe are saying don't wait too long
look at what's happened in this country
you've got to take action soon and
Martha just briefly that's what the
world of sport will be looking for from
this Cobra meeting today in terms of
this mass gatherings are stopped anytime
soon that has a huge hit on all your
casebook hmm we heard Nicola Sturgeon in
Scotland saying that she was minded in
to ban gatherings of over 500 people but
she was waiting the outcome of that
cobra meeting this afternoon but that is
something that particularly the Premier
League will be looking at where there is
the right course of action to hold games
behind closed doors in Liverpool of
course on the brink of their first
Premier League title and for 30 years
and they'll be wondering whether if
there is if the Premier League is
postponed and whether they are given
that title or not so there's plenty of
uncertainties around at the moment but
we do see him in NBA the American
basketball that's that leagues suspended
indefinitely at the moment and we've got
on Melbourne Grand Prix which incredibly
at the moment is still going ahead
despite the fact that McLaren one of the
teams has had to withdraw from that
Grand Prix because one of their staff
members has tested positive for Cove in
19 and that's caused a lot of
consternation and Lewis Hamilton
Britain's Formula one champion has said
he cannot believe they're still there he
says that their prizing money over
people safety the Premier League who
wants to be avoid being viewed in the
same way okay Martha thank you with
relation to those two new deaths
bringing the total number of UK deaths
to ten now
from cave-in 19 we've just had a
statement from the two hospitals
however those patients died yeah but the
first statement is from the Imperial
College Health Care Trust it says we can
confirm an 89 year old patient was very
unwell with underlying health conditions
has passed away Charing Cross Hospital
so that's in West London or central West
London an 89 year old patient the other
one is the statement is from The Barking
Havering & Redbridge University
Hospitals NHS Trust and they said we can
confirm that a patient who was in her
60s who tested positive for covert 19:00
and sadly died at Queen's Hospital she
had been very unwell with significant
other health conditions so every time we
read a statement like this the emphasis
is on age and underlying health
conditions
you